[Music]
hello everybody i'm grandmaster joel
Benjamin tonight is the Thursday night
class at the st. Louis chess club and
this is actually my my last night of
classes as the Grand Master in residence
it's it's been a blast being here and
also sending out shows to to our viewers
in cyberspace tonight's show this this
Thursday class is Grand Master choice so
my choice tonight is I want to educate
people on the advantage of the bishop
pair okay
everybody knows that two bishops
are an advantage we learned that from
pretty much from the beginning but to
actually feel what that means you know
why the bishop pair why it's better to
have two bishops and a bishop and a
night or two nights to actually kind of
internalize that and appreciate it is is
hard for a lot of amateur players so I
want to start off by showing maybe the
first real classic exploitation of the
bishop pair this there's a lot of other
great elements about this game as well
but you know the fact that it was played
back in 1883 that tells you that it's a
it's a pretty it's pretty old game I
wasn't even around back then and the
winner of this game is Willam Stein it's
one of the the all-time greats but
certainly the certainly the greatest
player in the world at the time and his
he's gonna be playing black in this game
white in this game is birch old English
who despite his name I think was
probably German or Austrian and so let's
get to it all right so English does not
open with the English opening he plays
e4
and so it's a classical opening which is
not really so surprising for 1883 was
but what perhaps is a little surprising
is we get a little fiend keto g6 you see
that Steinitz he he really was arguably
the first great player to really
incorporate modern ideas into his game
so he you know develops a bishop and
what we considered to be a pretty modern
way now white decides to open the center
with d4 and black takes and now white
takes back on d4 and this isn't actually
a very good move what's considered to be
the main move is Bishop g5 and now black
can do things like Bishop b4 check or f6
but they're both considered just to be
too dangerous to be opening up the King
Y can sacrifice a pawn favorably this
you know a lot of experience from the
position so what usually happens is
black plays Bishop e7 white takes which
also defends a pawn
Queen d4 and we get to a pawn structure
that's very much like the Royal Lopez
exchange variation but white hasn't
given up the bishop pair in this case
it's considered to be slightly better
for white although people still willing
to play it for black of course this
stuff was not known at the time also
interestingly white could play move like
c3 which is almost the same position
that we saw in a game between charissa
hip actually playing black and Jew and
Jun playing white the difference was the
pawn a six in Bishop retreats a four
were in in a game which famously was won
by 16 year-old Chris yet playing black
she did not take the pawn she just led
white have it back and continue her
development
but a thing about Knight takes d4 it's
really kind of an awkward move because
although this exchange is generally okay
for white this Bishop on b5 is now not
really well placed the whole idea of the
bishop coming to the b5 and the royal up
has to put pressure on the center it's
just kind of a target now and we're kind
of kind of see that in the coming moves
so now both players start developing
their pieces
and now in this position a very
natural-looking move is rook e8 and that
has been played in in this position by
other players it's a reasonable move but
it's not necessarily part of plan and
Steines has won two kind of free his
position and take the initiative at the
moment white we could say that white has
a slight space advantage because it's
pawn on e4 and is unopposed by any pawns
on the unblocks fourth rank it gives
them a little more space but that
actually disappears pretty quickly after
after the move Knight e7
do you guys have any idea what black is
is aiming for with that 97 yes exactly
he wants to play d5 in one move and d5
was not really on the table before
because that knight on c6 white had two
attackers of the knight on c6 so now now
black is ready to play d5 defended by
both of those knights and you can see
now now the bishop on b5 just looks out
of place just out there not really
functioning just kind of a target so
after ninety seven white played Queen d2
which in hindsight might seem a little
oblivious to what black is doing but it
does have a little idea to it black
plays d5 white takes it and block takes
with the knight which is most backward
right now to say preserve the other
night takes but in this position black
takes of the Queen Steines takes of the
Queen why not take with the knight
there's a reason why black didn't take
with the knight anybody on idea what
where white might go here
I mean tax the bishop the pot gets to
take the bishop that's good but the
problem is that white doesn't have to
let block take the bishop
like he could play Bishop h6 so
sometimes you have a move that has a
really nice idea that you like and you
might be tempted to throw it out there
but if your opponent can respond with a
move that that kind of messes up your
plans that dark square bishop on its its
glorious diagonal is getting traded so
Steinitz he took with the queen instead
now Bishop h6 is off the table because
black will take the bishop and the
knight will hang and also white is
starting to get nervous about this
Bishop on b5 because the knight is
protecting it and I don't know if
there's exactly a direct threat but
something like if this Knight let's say
jumped into e4 then they'd be possible
is that black could take the knight with
the bishop and maybe take the bishop so
it's white retreated this should be too
and now comes the move which makes the
game appropriate to this lesson Knight
g4 now it's not the only good move that
black has in the position but this
enables black tit - to have a long-term
advantage okay that Bishop pair can
persist persist from the opening to the
middle game to the endgame sometimes if
you have an advantage in development or
mobility that might be fleeting your
opponent might be able to catch up or
cover it up in a couple of months all
right
so white is gonna have to give a bishop
for a knight
if you are white in this position which
one would you give up would you let
black take on e3 or would you take the
knight on g4 50/50 proposition yeah I
think that's the right decision this is
a thing that's really not talked about
that much or not I don't really see it
in the literature but your minor pieces
are not created equal in any opening you
you have you have pieces that are a
little bit more important the the dark
squared bishop is a little bit more
important for white right now than the
white square especially because that
bishop on g7 is potentially a monster so
white is a lot happier to take this
knight and although he's given up the
the bishop pair
he still has a bishop that could impose
the bishop on g7 and that helps him but
here white definitely goes wrong and he
plays the move Knight b3 and this is
just too passive this lets Dinitz
consolidate his advantage that he's
gonna have this forever so the thing is
that black just spent a move getting the
bishop pair white has to fight back
first thing he could do is he can kick
this bishop now the bishop doesn't
really have a good place to go right now
a lot of squares are controlled by that
knight on d4 it may not be that safely
place in the center but it is there for
now if the bishop goes back to d7 y
could play a move like like rook d1
trying to create some threats against
the Queen and once that knight is
protected
then black starts sorry then white
starts to get ideas renewing this idea
of Bishop coming to h6 all right and if
the bishop if white is able to trade off
that pair of bishops then he's a lot
happier in
position so that was really that was
really White's last hope of having a
chance to equalize from now on he's
basically groveling and that's something
you never want to do sometimes sometimes
people will accept a worse position
against a stronger player because they
figure well I'm really happy with a draw
so if I have a passive position I can
still make a draw but the passive
position is really the seeds of defeat
so black took night takes and I guess
the big idea for white was that after
Bishop takes B - we can play rook be one
that's caching and way too quick because
white will take this point on b7 and get
lots of counter play there's no reason
to allow that so he does not so instead
after Knight takes D - you just you know
what he normally just brings his pieces
into the center Bishop of course can't
take a seven because T - so white blocks
the tag no block puts his other rook and
black incidentally has a little threat
yeah little tactical threat after
putting both rooks in the center minor
piece is kind of depending on each other
so block to move would be able to win
those two pieces for a rook
yes rook takes e3 well it takes e3 is a
threat so white move the knight to b3 so
Steinitz now over the next several moves
shows part of the strategy of playing
against Knights okay you know bishops
have their diagonals they can reach for
out but Knights Knights play on squares
so as you take squares away from from
the night the night becomes less and
less useful so black starts using his
pawns and this is really now a classic
strategy using his pawns to take away
squares from the night anybody want to
propose what the first move in this plan
might be
yeah b6 absolutely now a lot of players
who are just thinking of this move you
know just to just to save their a pawn
might say okay I could push my a pole
and then it can't be taken and that's
very true but b6 now black is ready to
do to put another pawn forward and take
away another square
if white played if white played the
Bishop to d4 then black doesn't even
necessarily have to trade you can just
play f6 and then c5 comes next move
white does not achieve the trade of the
bishops so after b6 white played h3
Bishop retreated to e6 that's a
beautiful diagonal as well because it's
it's skewering white it's looking at
this a pond behind the knight which also
limits the Knights movement rook ft 1
and now c5 just strangling that height
white plays Bishop g5 now there's not a
whole lot white can really do to help
himself here and he was hoping okay
maybe I'll get the D file black just
goes f6 and Steines is actually
perfectly happy with this because now
now he's got this idea to push the King
side pawns forward and when you have the
bishop pair it's often nice to to
advance with your pawns very often on
both sides because if you can pressure
your opponent on both wings
very classical approach if you could put
pressure on two fronts it makes it a lot
harder to defend so he starts he starts
getting that going Bishop f4 I guess
with some ideas maybe going to c7 at
some point King f7 f3 now this does help
the King come to the center but after
the move g5 then there's a little issue
with the white issue for white that the
bishop can't retreat to this natural
square III what happens if white tries
to retreat the Bishop to e3
you should take something
not exactly what's the most precise way
to do this
what move do you want to start with do
you want to start with Bishop takes b3
or is there more accurate way to do it
exactly you trade rooks first because
otherwise white will throw and rook
takes d8 and and lower your rook away
from the e-file
so B rook takes d1 rook takes t1 Bishop
b3 and the bishop I need three Hanks
okay so that that explains why after
after f6 so I have to g5 rather white
took on d8 because he wanted to retreat
but now black has total control over the
D file and as we go along and can say
like yeah it looks like white is making
making some mistakes here I'm making a
little bit easier but that that's how it
goes when you're in a position like this
it's very easy to see your your position
go downhill bit by bit because you're
squeezed do you have nothing to do and
your opponent is just ready to pounce on
on anything any missed mistake or any
weakness in your position so steinitz
plays h6 so he's getting ready to move
the F pawn forward and also open his
Bishop up again the white has this real
problem now that he he can't challenge
for the D file he's never going to be
able to take that back
he's never gonna really be able to deal
ineffective way with his pressure from
the bishop on e6 alright say plays rook
e1 f5 and now he tries to fight back
with that for now if he hadn't done this
black would be in position to still have
a general advance of the Kings side
pawns maybe a four thought by age 5 and
g5 well among other things if he chases
the bishop from e3 it either has to go
although back to c1 which among other
things would take a square away from the
knight or it would have to leave the
defense of the f2 d2 square so white is
desperately trying to hold on to
control of this invasion square so
Bishop f6 just guarding that improving
the bishop g3 and now black advances on
the other wing and basically this is
going to drive the knight back to c1
where it's pretty dead it just has no
place to go but otherwise that a2 pawn
will disappear so white goes back on its
own accord
a4 and now black is threatening to
disrupt the pawn formation by playing a3
so white plays a3 himself you know maybe
doesn't mind it that much because it
freezes Knight a little bit but it
doesn't you know it doesn't free and
unfree it all that all that much now
when we first got into this ending the
first thing that was happening was the
Bishop on g7 the dark square Bishop was
was dominant and white kind of took some
steps to try to negate that he put a lot
of pawns on dark squares to block the
diagonal he has a bishop that can help
out but in the meantime the the
LightSquared Bishop has become pretty
strong for black and dominant against
the night and now Steinitz plays a move
that that indicates the complete
domination of the bishop versus the
knight
absolutely
I mean that that's like an encyclopedia
picture you know for domination
literally any square the night goes to
the bishop can take it that bishop
basically owns the night so it's a tough
situation for for for white you know
maybe he could he could try to run with
the knight right away to e2 but there
are there are various problems with that
black could try to to use the pin on the
e-file he could possibly even take the
knight and try to and bring the rook
down to the to the eighth-ranked this
would be one possible think that black
could do he could he could try something
like check King comes up and put the
rook on beat on b1 and that would you
know that would be tying white down
pretty much permanently I'm not sure
that what the what the next plan would
be but that's one possibility that could
be unpleasant for white but you know it
wasn't worse than what he did he played
King f2
and okay so now with the night driven
back to see one right it was on B 3 on B
3 it was it had the function of
defending D 2 so now Steines is thinking
well I want to set up to invade with my
rook to d2 now can anyone see a possible
plan that's a couple move plan for black
to try to free up that D 2 square for
invasion
bhante except for GTA except for
Bishop
hold on I think you misspoke slightly
because because you said you said black
starts with gf4 you actually said I
think G takes out for for white which
which which you can't do you can't do
because of the of Bishop h4 check so
what you what you really meant to say
was was Bishop takes f4 and and and then
Bishop g5 and that's exactly what he did
now this this this brings us to a very
important point about the bishop pair
one of the strengths of the bishop pair
is that you can usually control the
moment you you cash it in you give up
that advantage for something else okay
because we see that White's attempt to
trade the bishops when he wanted to
black said uh-uh but now because the
bishop pair has helped make all this
progress now black wants that trade
because that leaves two minor pieces on
the board the one that black has
obviously way better than the one that
white has and what to do about white
coming into into d2 well he has to play
he's going to have to put his his King
on an e3 to be able to to keep that rook
out and I think that he would have given
himself rather more chances if he had
done it right away
although we have a position where white
hardly can move anything so black is is
very likely to to do to do something
advantageous but when white took on g5
that strained out the pawns and that
that you know gay black an extra
opportunity now this game already
appears in in one of my books it's
actually going to appear at another book
that I'm I'm working on now okay and the
the book that it appears in is
liquidation on the chessboard
mastering the transition into the pawn
endgame because already you can start to
see a pawn endgame coming because Black
has the possibility of trading rooks
with rookie a check and then once that
happens it's basically already upon
endgame because white at some point is
going to have to play 92 or possibly 93
because otherwise it's basically black
just playing with an extra Bishop so
then I can't move anywhere else
so now the point it's not we're not
really ready for the pawn endgame and we
have to take we have to keep in mind
that white potentially has an outside
past pawn in a in a pawn ending so we
may not want that but for now steinitz
improves his King maybe maybe prepping
for it and English decided to try to
create some immediate count to play with
the movement with the move h4 and now we
get pretty much my favorite thing in in
chess the liquidation into the ending
after h4 black takes and now this is
this is just a matter of calculation you
know sometimes you can't see right away
how this is going to lead but Steinitz
worked out that this ending is going to
be winning for him a White has the
outside past pawn can you see where
black is going to have an advantage in
this pawn ending what is going to be
superior about the black position
we started to see with his King f6 he's
he's got dominant King position exactly
so he checks and the King which way did
it go it went it went to f2 he traded
and now he came in
so after king e5 white played 92 and you
could say well why is he going to the
point a well what else can he do
blacks next move can be king out for you
you pretty much gonna have to do it
anyway otherwise you're basically
playing the piece down say plays 92 and
one thing about about chess is that
about endings is the pawn ending is the
simplest purest element if the pawn
ending is a demonstrable win and you
know and you know how to win it you
should always head to it there's just no
variables there's no the opponent can
move a piece around and try four tricks
there's no pieces to move around so
Steines goes for the ending and it works
because he has this dominant king
position and he's ready to go right
after that point and of course if he
manages to to take that pawn safely he's
going to have he's going to have an
outside pass pawn and he's going to be
able to win with that so white basically
just had one last trick that he could
play for and first first he played the
move c4 it doesn't really have any
difference whether make any difference
where that point is there or not it it
does take away some reserve pawn moves
on the Queen side for black but he
doesn't need them anyway so after c4 he
goes king g4 and white plays King III so
this is this is White's big idea okay so
after King III
should black take this pawn on h4 no no
no no no no why is it a big mistake to
take that pawn in h4 absolutely big
mistake and this phrase has come up in a
few classes I've done here that some
some amateur players sometimes take
first ask questions later very very bad
way to play that that way can you know
get you a zero in a position where you
should have a full point now now White
has the advantage because his King is
closer but Steines didn't fall for that
he played he played f4 check and that is
a dilemma for white because if the King
comes back black will just take the pawn
and then he could win very simply either
by pushing the pawn all the way to the
seventh rank whether he has the
opposition or not because he can still
meet the king and make white give up the
b-pawn and then take that and queen and
yeah that's a simple way or if he wants
he can use the F pawn to maneuver his
King over to the Queen side and eat all
of those pawns and make a queen it's
pretty simple either way so white tries
kingi for but the problem is that in
trying to maintain contact with his pawn
he's losing all this time and now black
is just simply winning the race and here
white resigns if h5 f2 and the black
pawn Queens too fast of kingi to King g2
it gets through anyway so you know that
was textbook
Bishop pair in the end game and played
1883 I don't know if you could find a
better illustrative game or a more more
modern exposition of that bishop
advantage in the endgame but that's
that's one of my very very
favorite game and it's my it's my what's
my favorite strategical steinitz game I
still love Steinitz longboarder laban
because that's a that's a crowd-pleaser
and very good very popular with the
kiddies I show that one and in class a
lot so let's see next I want to show you
a more modern game with the with the
bishop pair and and this is going to be
an exploitation of the bishop pair in
the in the middle game for attack which
is which is also very very important to
our understanding of the bishop pair
this is a game that I saw personally
although not not very happily because my
teammate got absolutely destroyed in
this game and it was God Akatsuki
playing against Garry Kasparov in the
Menil Olympiad in 1992 Kamsky was only
about 18 years old at first time in the
American team and it seemed like is
maybe his nerves got him a little bit in
this game as he did not put his best
foot forward against the greatest player
in the world
all right so Kamsky is playing white cos
borrow blood and it's going to be Kings
Indian
you know many of our many of our viewers
may have taken up chess after gaspar are
retired which is a little mind-blowing
for me and maybe don't really know that
much about him but he was an incredibly
dynamic player great tactics great at
seeking out the initiative and he was
not afraid to take on the Kings Indian
defense for black which most
grandmasters said all this is just this
is bad white gets too much space you
don't want to play like this but he
could make it work
all right so black so so white has that
space advantage and Kasparov decides to
try to open this position up a little
bit and create some play on the Queen
side so can't he develops the bishop so
that he can have a square on e 2 for the
night but Castro says well I haven't
forgotten about this side of the board
Knight h5 now White's certainly doing
fine at this point the engine is
actually really quite like White's
position and I'm sure it's a well-known
theoretical position I don't really know
why Kamsky did not play simply 92 and if
f5 I don't know I suppose white could
could certainly contemplate castling on
either side of the board but he made it
kind of a kind of a surprising error
this moved g4
I'm not really sure what what he was
thinking with that move because you know
he was already a grandmaster he
understood that this night was going to
jump in to have four and that night will
happily jump into f4 in the King's
Indian a lot the fact that White has
more attackers and defenders on on this
square at the Grand Master level is
really kind of meaningless now I can
take this night and take this pawn and
there's actually a few occasions where
he can take that night and grab the pawn
and from from a high level perspective
on chess this is actually a real
no-brainer I mean for amateur plays it's
not so clear but this diet long diagonal
is really devastating and also white has
compromising position with this point on
g4 so probably black just just continues
with with with b5 and what is white
gonna do I mean it's gonna be difficult
to even protect that pawn on b2 he can
try to protect it by castling queenside
but black is going to have a pretty
devastating attack for instance you if
you Castle queenside now just as one
possibility something like this and
already though the king is getting into
trouble so it's one of those things
where
lower-rated players might look at this
position and say okay can I take that
pawn and and the answer they're looking
for is do I see a tactical way in which
my position will be blown apart and a
higher-level way of thinking about it is
it just doesn't matter because black has
so many strategical Trump's in this
position that long diagonal is murderuss
the knight can potentially come to d7
and jump into one of these squares on e5
and c5 and there's something else about
this position and the game we just saw
when when Steinitz won the bishop pair
his opponent could at least satisfy
himself in the fact that he still was
opposing black strongest bishop here
black has a devastating dark square
bishop white does not have the dark
squared bishop in fact in King's Indian
the most important position I call it
the glue piece for white is it dark
square bishop you almost never can give
up that bishop and not get back the
other bishop for it
so why cannot oppose that long that that
dark squared bishop but also his light
squared Bishop is useless its hemmed in
by all these pawns it can't attack
anything can't really defend anything
useful it's such a useless minor piece
and all the other all the black pieces
are just great so Kamsky got that and so
he played Bishop C - he played Bishop C
- but his plan to challenge this night
is so long-winded I don't know you know
why he thought that that this this could
work and cuz bran just you know got to
business with b5
and now Kamsky ends up wasting a little
bit more time he could challenge the
knight right away with night GE too but
he didn't want to do that why didn't he
want to play Knight GE - right away
that would allow black to play a move
that he didn't have less on the last
turn well that's not really the problem
seeing this position you're not you have
things covered but when white puts the
night I need to you've uncovered a
square you've uncovered the G to square
that's kind of an easy thing to to miss
that's why it's very important to really
well visualize the position before you
make a move and to be aware of the
differences from your piece being on
once one square another what what
function it performed where it was okay
black is gonna take the bishop with the
knight he's gonna get rid of that glue
piece and then he might even think about
playing f5 and blasting open the
position because he is such a huge
advantage on the dark squares and also
the white King is gonna have to move
somewhere it's doesn't really want to be
on d1 blocking the rooks but if it goes
to the Kings side then then black has
all the more reason to blast open that
so he ended up losing more time by
playing Queen f2
so after queen f2 that's that's another
tempo for for black to mobilize and she
plays Knight whoops
he plays 97 Knight G 2 and so Kamsky is
thinking okay
well after executing all these moves I
force him to do something with the night
he could trade okay then I'm happy I got
rid of that night if he plays something
like g5 that solidifies the knight but
then white you know getting compensation
gets this nice square and also the
Bishop on g7 is crying after black plays
g5 because it has absolutely no chance
of getting in the game in sharp contrast
to what happened but because Bob
realizes that there's actually just no
threat at all in the positions before
for white because if white takes on f4
he opens up that Bishop again so he just
gets to his business he plays b4 and the
knight doesn't really have great square
it can go back to d1 and you know black
will pretty much do the same thing same
thing he does in the game just plays a5
what's the mate what's the main point of
the move a five the main purpose of that
move
he's getting ready to activate the
bishop day six and we see he we see that
the bishop on see - that's the bad
bishop that's the problem peace in the
Kings in the end when that bishop gets
day six it's obviously going to be a
much better peace so now there's a lot
of pressure on White's position it's
kind of hard to resist this trade
anymore so he takes so he managed to win
that pawn and keep his his dark squared
Bishop but how much is it really going
to help because now black occupies this
great square 95 okay the white King
can't stay in the center forever you
could certainly make an argument that
white would be relatively safer castling
kingside in this position that maybe he
can better protect the King over there
because at the very least the bishop on
g7 isn't pointing at the king and I
haven't really investigated what black
would do against that but one
possibility is that he he might he might
very well consider this typical Kings
Indian move f5 blasting away there
because he's going to at the very least
have one strong piece coming to e5
whatever whatever white does you know
maybe maybe he would you know play a
slightly different way maybe would just
play like in the game night c4 and just
target that point on b2 which actually
is pretty pretty hard to defend and
castling queenside does actually does
actually help defend the pawn of b2 but
i don't know if that's really such a
great reason for playing this move and
Kasparov jumps in Knight c4 anyway and
we see the problem that even though
white has maintained the dark squared
bishop he's not in really in a position
to oppose it oppose the doorpost a
bishop on g7 and black is developing
threats
one is the bishop coming to d7 to remove
the defender another is queen coming to
f6 tagging the bishop attacking b2 it's
kind of hard to see a normal way to
defend against these threats so Kamsky
plays Bishop e3 but we see that now this
grand plan of forcing something to
happen on f4 without giving up the
dark-squared bishop in the end the dark
squared bishop is going anyway and black
does not hesitate to take it because if
he doesn't the bishop goes to d4
neutralizes blacks bishops so he gets
rid of that now this bishop is
permanently unopposed on this long
diagonal and that's really the plan from
now on is to basically win with the with
the power of that Bishop so the first
thing he does is he plays rook to b8 to
keep the knight from jumping into b6 and
black has his plan he's just going to
attack that guy so Bishop comes to b3 if
he doesn't do that black after this
Bishop d7 was really gonna threaten to
play b3 anyway because then then after Y
takes on b3 black could take the knight
and once once the rook and the bishop
converge on this b to pawn the white
king is going to be in really huge
trouble so white played King b1 and
black jumped with Queenie ain't
tonight to be six
this should be five so the night got off
the edge but it didn't really help all
that much black activate this Bishop and
he's ready to push forward a four so now
we're getting into moments of
desperation for white because you know
black is is is getting ready to really
crunch on the the Queen side so Kamsky
makes a defensive move rook t2 and he
pushes a four and Bishop t1
Lucas bar plays rook d7 so he's got this
idea he's playing against this night on
on b6 rook b7 in a kind of coy way
actually prepares a potential doubling
on the B file and white has the ID black
has the idea that he can he can double
the Queen the Queen and and rook on the
B file to attack the knight and that
will create problems so Kamsky in
desperation mode went for this move e5
okay if black takes with the Bishop III
dia would be maybe I guess it would be
to play f4 attack the bishop and then
when the bishop moves why it's gonna
trade Queen's huge sigh of relief
actually the knight can even come out
and take the pawn in a four D takes e5
is also something black doesn't want to
do because first of all it blocks the
bishop but secondly it gives up the
blockade in the center you notice that
that even though white was a pawn up it
wasn't a very effective pawn because
black was holding White's pawn majority
from moving completely with that dark
square blockade but suddenly after d6
then it is counter playing the position
so Kamsky I mean he was a strong player
he had a good idea there but but on e5
this is one of those moments where I can
say it's it's not checkers you know he
doesn't have to take and if I have to
pawn his pinned for one thing so
Kasparov really just falls through this
plan
and one part of the plan is he's going
to attack the knight right now if he
attacks a knight directly the knight can
come back and take the pawn on a form so
he wants to set things up first so he
makes a move on the Queen side so that
when he attacks the night the night is
not really going to be able to come back
in a safe way either safe for the night
or safe for the white king
it's a it it's almost a kind of
desperado move right if you play Queen
at b8 Knight takes a for the black sees
that that pawn is gonna drop but he
wants to drop it you know in a very in a
way that's more effective and opens
lines against the white king
so he pushed b3 now you might be tempted
to push a three but a three I suppose
white can play b3 and even though the
diagonal is open he's kept other things
closed but once he plays b3 that creates
a big time crisis for white because at
this moment white the White Knight has
no retreat squares so black goes in
attacks that night it's it's gone so
Kamsky has to do something he really
doesn't want to do he has to take this
pawn if he doesn't think the point is
gonna lose tonight
it's not gonna have anything forward so
he takes the pawn black takes back and
he takes the pawn again but now in black
plays Queen to b8 we see that when the
knight retreats the B file is wide open
suddenly black has two heavy pieces
pounding down on the the B file so white
retreats the knight and now we get now
we get one of those classic moments in
in our analysis of the two bishops why
it's such a great advantage is because
once again we see black having an option
of of trading in that advantage of the
bishop pair for something else so he
actually does it for the bishop of
opposite colors position now there's a
portent rule of thumb about bishops
opposite colors many people know that
bishop solid colors are a draws force
force in the endgame but in the middle
game they're often the complete opposite
this the rule of thumb is that bishop of
opposite colors favors the attacker or
favors the one with the initiative and
that's because white has no defense on
the dark squares all right I mean this
could also be this game could also be
illustrative of you know dark Square
disasters
that's that's really where the the
bishop pair did him in and although
white is able to defend the pawn for the
time being with with b3 Gaspar EV is
really is really not very concerned
about bringing this pawn home because he
knows that he just has to I'm sorry he
actually did not play b3 I guess he
would come to the a file quicker he
knows that he just has to put a little
bit of pressure on the white king and
he's got one more piece to to mobilize
to do that and then things are gonna
start crashing down so so he actually
plays Queen e2 Kamsky is trying to avoid
the move b3 because he doesn't want to
give access to the a1 square which
starts driving his King up but it
doesn't matter because after Queen a7
that's going to happen anyway
white plays rook c1 black plays rook c8
work a8 rather now he plays b3 because
otherwise queen a1 and rook takes the
pawn on b2 so he can't keep him out
she plays b3 and now he's not gonna go
in there unless he has a way to make
progress and the you come in the King
can the King will be driven out to C 2
and D 1 and and once if white is able to
get the King out then he might survive
so he's not in a rush he can do that any
time
but first black makes a very simple move
he just shows you know white that in his
in his desperation to protect his King
he wasn't protecting his pieces
he left his rooks cute in skewer
position and that's exactly what happens
he he skewers now it's not necessarily
the case that he's going to take right
away but just the fact that that those
rooks become hanging means that that
creates possibilities of the pieces
falling and that's that's what's gonna
happen just a couple moves he plays King
c2 because otherwise we could have seen
the Queen come in and then the rook come
into a2 and and take on d2 and I suspect
at this point there are already many
many many ways for black to win but I
think it's kind of instructive that I'd
say the average player would probably
get fixated in that penetration I know
that a lot of players would probably
just take the rook or maybe play Queen
a2 and take on d2 and maybe you're
winning that position with a exchange
for a pawn but white certainly can still
play but instead spar off goes to the
e-file so one thing he's doing is that
if white has any hopes of running out
with his kin
he's cut nowhere to run to now he just
jumps forward with the Queen so he's got
rooks coming in on both sides of the
King and now a huge threat of rook a to
because the rook coming there was much
stronger threat because then he's going
to take the rook on d2 and and basically
that the the white position starts
starts falling apart
he tries rook b1 to be able to block
this check rook III Queen d4 and now
this is just you know a matter of he's
starting to calculate forced wins
rook b2 it's a move he did not play but
if he played rook b2 black has a very
simple way to win a big chunk of
material then you might kind of notice
it in the relationship of where those
white pieces have just moved and how
they relate to each other so can you see
how bad tactical situation is is it's
coming up here for Wyatt
well just picture if black makes a
couple of exchanges here if he takes the
Queen and he takes the rook
yeah that's one thing that can happen
yeah
that's a bad pin because you can't
defend it
so that's that's a rook you know so it's
like when you're trying to say okay
what's the what's the best I can slime
out of this being down a ruckus is not
good enough so he so he plays King d1 so
King g1 was played in the game and now
Kasparov makes a bit of a slick move and
the game ends right away I mean he could
he can win in many many different ways
but he he looks at this relationship
here the rook on d2 and he's got this
bishop almost attacking it but the rook
is in the way and he comes up with a
clever move because you know most
amateur players their first thought
would be well I can play rook takes rook
Queen takes rook and then a rook move
and hit the queen but Gaspar just took
on f3 right away and that's really
really devastating because there are two
captures that white can make and they
both completely lose if you take the
rook the d4 the Queen is hanging on d4
and if you you take on c5 then rook
takes d2 happened and I think he
actually did play another move he's
stubborn a little stubborn he took the
bishop on f4 and okay maybe he'd have
some hopes of limping on with rook and
Bishop for the Queen but after Queen g1
he's going to lose the rook on a two-two
you know Queen Queen h2 or Queen f2
check next depending on what what white
plays it's it's going to be a massacre
there so so so that was so he he
actually played king c2 and resigned
after Queen h2
so we see an example of strength of the
bishop pair in the middle game and how
it can lead to an attack and one one
thing to look for when you're thinking
about how powerful is the bishop pair is
you know that unopposed bishop
and when I say unopposed bishop I mean
it's the bishop you don't have the
bishop that that matches it on on that
color complex so you can't trade it for
the bishop you can't block it with your
bishop if that's if that's a
particularly strong piece that's bad
that's bad for you it's bad for the
player without the bishop pair and also
if the remaining bishop the one that hat
wasn't traded is the bad bishop and
that's really bad and that's what Kamsky
had in this game and it was a perfect
storm and that and that led to to total
disaster okay so that that's that's our
bishop pair lecture for tonight there is
an another class coming up after this
which is games from recent events and if
you stick around for that one it it's a
we've gotta sort of morph this one into
that one because the first game from
recent event is going to involve the
bishop pair so we'll see that in in a
few minutes but in the meantime I want
to to thank everybody no audience out in
cyberspace who was watching tonight
pleasure to bring this chest to you and
of course a thank our live audience it's
always much better than we have a live
audience as well so that that was fun
and I've had it had a blast of doing
these classes that I can't believe it's
it's almost over and time to go home but
anyway i'm grandmaster joel benjamin i
hope you enjoyed this class and
see you around
[Music]
you